public plantea y caso Stecca un desafe
Yo para la custissimi al americana
ser un ex presidente
tiene un ex presidente
paranoiardicas una percepción que no
tienes escapes o pararmismo es lo mejor
representante del país que luego será
acusado es una mentalidad de su
secretos injustamente sí, sí
Claro es Algo que es Marco en la historia
Siempre si lo recordará y en el futuro en
futuro único
fue porque como Sanremo
va a Ponente tipo de mentalidad de
responder como
normalmente atacando al oeste eloiso
atacando al fiscal eloiso de Nueva York
éramos Severa ahora y marrago vamos
repite otra vez que es malo
brucas y que sus sustentadores sostienen
también seguir colocando la prehensión arriba
del congreso en particular e
prepárese para la resistencia al masnetol
no tiene negras para defender su defensa y
Sabíamos que durante sus últimos Pocos.
La reincidencia entró en los seis millones
dólares S Diosa Poe Apple Fuente
partidarios
Roma caracterizó el proceso como uno
casariale rucas il porto parteoil
impuesto
Por supuesto, la política siempre influye.
es un camino más allá de un Induno
rango completamente imparcial aunque es
el oeste que el director había presidido
Yo los habría aprendido a cambio.
la organización
de la sociedad y del Sr.
Westernberg y el asistente financiero
de dicha RAM y optovo es una evaluación
nosotros muybuena Pol parte de la OMS
ellos observaron
en el diente anhelas y luego viene
Espero que Elba no siga
mantennos profesionales y vamos a
passiguar tigamos People's Lost Mores
que es un teatro también se puede hacer hml que
un permiso y el uso de la televisión
que serie un muro interesante Claro e
uno instructivo
y no fueron mucho es el Axeso de Pario
distancia a la sala del tribunal
para demostrar que luchan en serio y
en el camino de respetar a Trump como
un batán acusado que aguanta el dia
y en la cancha y eso puede dependencias
con la ayuda de su abogado si Clarice
va